- A debate is contentious.
A debate is about winning.
A conversation is about
truth seeking together.
When I saw the "debate"
devolve into personal attacks
I felt like that was a
loss for me as a viewer.
Hey guys, I want to talk about
this new Netflix documentary
called The Game Changers.
It's all the buzz in town.
My patients are asking about it.
You're asking about it.
So, I decided that I'm gonna
make a video on the topic,
but instead of overloading
you with a ton of information,
I decided to source three of
the most popular questions
that you have and three of
that my patients have.
And I'm gonna answer
them within this video.
Full disclosure, not only did
I watch the entire documentary
but I also watched both episodes
of the Joe Rogan podcast.
The first where he had Chris Kresser on
essentially debunking the documentary
and then the second one where
he brought in James Wilks
from the documentary to have
a debate with Chris Kresser
about those qualms.
That's in total about
seven hours of footage.
I watched it all.
I wanted to make sure I came prepared
my baseline thoughts on the subject
going into watching the documentary
so that you could be aware
of my cognitive biases.
Now, we all have a bias.
In fact when I watched the
debate between James and Chris
on Rogan's podcast, I saw
their cognitive biases showing.
And I think if you're more
aware of my cognitive biases
and where I'm starting,
my starting point is,
you'll be able to make a better judgment
as to whether or not the information
I'm presenting you is accurate
or where it's coming from
and why I think what I do think.
As a board certified
family medicine doctor
who's done a lot of
research on the subject,
the recommendation I give
most often to my patients
is a whole foods, primarily
plant focused diet.
It doesn't mean vegan.
It means getting the
majority of your calories
from non-animal sources.
But it also means it's
okay to eat fish, meats,
albeit red meat in
moderation, and removing
to the greatest extent
possible processed meats.
Now, in this diet you'll
have a lot of fruits,
vegetables, healthy fats like
avocado, nuts, olive oil,
things like that.
It's actually quite close
to the Mediterranean diet.
We have to remember though
that nutrition advice
should be really given
on an individual level,
so I don't recommend
that to all my patients.
That's sort of my general advice,
and then we make little
changes based on that person's
body, their health, their conditions
and what they hope to achieve.
So, while I've never
explicitly recommended
the vegan diet to somebody,
if a patient comes in
and wants to, I make sure they do it
to the best of their abilities.
Supplementing, blood
testing, and making sure
they're planning to get
the right macronutrients.
Let's get into my thoughts before we jump
into the questions.
I'm really happy this
documentary was made.
It's debunking a lot of the
myths we've been propagating
for such a long period of time,
like we need to eat a
certain amount of meat
in order to put on muscle.
A lot of these have
been proven to be untrue
and I'm happy that this documentary
is putting it out there.
In fact, I'm happy that
we're discussing nutrition.
We're actually learning
about what constitutes
good research, why we're
so mislead with the certain
headlines that we see in media.
I love that we're discussing this.
I mean, this video, Rogan's
video, the documentary itself,
all the response videos,
this is all healthy debate
that we need to do more
and more often in nutrition
so that we can raise the bar
on the type of research we're doing.
We can actually make a meaningful impact
on the future generations
with nutrition research.
That being said, the
science of the documentary
is pretty solid.
All the facts are well stated.
There's sources for everything
that appear on screen.
I love that.
In fact in a lot of my
videos I try and put links
for further reading
from major organizations
like WHO, CDC, or if I'm
referencing a specific study
I put that study in there as well.
The one thing that I will
say is I do feel it was made
from an activist scientist standpoint.
The reason I have to make that a point is
they didn't present any counter-arguments.
And when you're making a documentary
I think it's in the
documentary's best interest
if the documentary's
interest is truth seeking
to put all perspectives in
there, at least the most
common ones so that we
can as viewers decide
for ourselves what's real, what's not.
Now, the experts that they had in the film
are credible experts.
They're some of the leading
experts in the world
but when you only have
them speaking about it
and no one else from the other
side of this conversation
you're leaving a void in
there and it feels like
it's been done intentionally
from an activist standpoint.
Now, I don't want to put blame on anybody
or assume why that's being done.
I just think that it would have
been a more complete picture
had we heard from the other
side of the conversation
about perhaps how much meat is healthy.
Is no meat healthy?
And sort of get a little
bit more details on that.
Now, James Wilks who is
the star and co-producer
of the film explicitly stated
that his goal with the film
wasn't to make everyone go vegan.
It was to reduce the
amount of animal products
that they're taking.
I love that goal.
I think we should all
be thinking about that,
especially for the environment's sake.
But what it feels like
in watching this film
and speaking to many people about it,
my patients included, the
vibe that everyone gets
from watching it is that eating
any amount of animal product
is incredibly unhealthy.
And we're gonna be getting
into that as we move forward
in this video, but I
feel that if your goal
was to send one message but in reality
or from a practical
standpoint you're sending
a different message, I
think something needs
to be adjusted.
When you're comparing
animal food companies
to tobacco companies
and we're talking about
dangerous words like inflammation, cancer
and referencing that only
in terms of animal products,
you're essentially scaring
people off in totality from it,
at least in their minds.
So, we need to be really
careful from not only
are we presenting all of
the information factually
but also how is it being
understood by the audience.
Let's start off with
the YouTube questions.
The first one was the
most upvoted and it was,
"Is it true that all
protein comes from plants
"and that animals are
just a vehicle for that?"
I think when we're making
these types of reductionist
statements we can really get lost
as to the practical value of them.
Let's use a metaphor.
All people were once
lower forms of organisms
because of evolution, so
we were once bacteria.
Does it mean we're technically bacteria?
Not really, and the fact that
a cow can eat a ton of grass
and make it into a lot
of protein does not mean
that we can eat that
same grass and turn it
into a lot of protein.
There's differences
between animals and humans,
so don't know what to
make of that statement.
I hope that answers your question.
Question number two, "Will going vegan
"give me more energy?"
First of all, it depends
what are you switching from
and what are you switching to?
If you're switching from a very unhealthy,
let's say the American standard
diet where you're eating
a ton of burgers and pepperoni
pizzas and things like that
and then you switch to
a healthy vegan diet,
you're gonna feel like
you have a lot of energy.
But now on the other hand, let's
say you were eating already
a Mediterranean diet and now
you switch to a vegan diet
but one that's unhealthy.
You're eating a ton of refined
carbs, processed foods.
They're still vegan.
You're not gonna see a
dramatic increase in energy.
In fact your energy levels may fall.
I don't think it's a magic
pill like in the documentary
some of the athletes said,
"Oh, before I was performing
"so horribly and now all of
a sudden I have more energy."
If they were eating
healthy before and switched
to a vegan diet, I don't
know how much we can say
that it was the vegan diet
that caused it directly.
Perhaps in individuals we can say that,
but not as a general rule.
We haven't seen the evidence for that.
Question number three,
"How did you feel about
"the experiments that
they showed in the film?"
That was probably one of my
biggest issues with the film.
I understand what they're going for.
They're trying to debunk
a lot of these myths
surrounding performance and masculinity
and how you can be vegan and still do well
in all these aspects of
your life and that's true.
But I wish they didn't resort
to a lot of these examples
that weren't scientifically meaningful.
Like, what does it mean
to see triglycerides
floating in your blood?
What does it mean that
these three gentlemen
didn't have the proper erections at night
when they ate something else?
It's not a controlled experiment.
There is so many variables at play
and the sample size is tiny.
I understand why they had to
do these visual demonstrations
because it works really
well in the documentary.
In fact when producers
call me to do morning shows
or daytime talk shows, they always ask me
to bring in demonstrations just like that
or little experiments.
But unless I can say
they're scientifically valid
or whatever it is I'm proving makes sense
I don't feel that I should
do it because I don't want
to mislead the audience by any means.
All right, let's move on
to the patient questions.
These are the ones that
are the primary questions
that seemingly everyone had.
The meat of the discussion if you will.
Question number one, "I'm
looking to put on muscle
"and I want to go vegan.
"Can I still put on size?"
Absolutely, yes, and I think the strength
of this documentary was
debunking that old myth
that you couldn't be
vegan and put on muscle.
You absolutely can.
You have to plan accordingly,
supplement accordingly,
making sure that you meet all
of your amino acid demands.
But outside of that, make sure you have
a good workout routine.
I'm actually gonna be showing
you my workout routine
in a video coming soon.
Are there any health
concerns with going vegan
and can we all go vegan?
The vegan diet is one that's appropriate
for all life stages.
They said it in the documentary
and I couldn't agree more with that.
It's not necessarily the
first diet that I reach for
when I recommend it to my patients
but it absolutely can work.
It's just important
that it's appropriately
and well planned.
And I know in the Joe Rogan debate
James made a point in saying all diets
need to be well planned.
This is true but the vegan
diet does require more effort
in that you really need
to plan your protein,
your supplementation, and you generally
don't have to do that if you're
eating an omnivorous diet.
If you do happen to go vegan
but do it in an unhealthy
or an unplanned way, you could actually
do serious harm to your body.
You can develop B-12 deficiency
which will lead to anemia.
You can develop other vitamin
or mineral deficiencies,
most notably vitamin D and calcium.
And also, if you're
trying to put on muscle,
if you're not planning your
protein sources correctly,
you could also get in trouble in that way
but for more people that
shouldn't be much of a problem.
And the mac daddy of them
all, the final question,
the question that so many
people have asked me,
the question I've even
pondered after watching
the documentary myself.
Are meat or animal products
as unhealthy as they say
and do I need to get rid of
all of them to stay healthy?
I rarely am so blunt in
answering questions like this
because there's usually a lot of nuance,
but the answer is no.
I think the documentary
went one step too far
in fear mongering people to eliminate meat
out of their diets completely.
In fact James on the
Joe Rogan podcast said
that frankly that he believes
that no amount of meat
is safe or healthy.
I don't that's the case.
I don't think evidence has
proven that to be the case.
I think we just don't know enough.
I think the research that
we have is really flawed.
We have industry funded
research, underfunded research,
research that's done with questionnaires.
My answer would be if
you're eating a healthy,
whole foods, plant focused
diet, and you eat some meat,
I think that's a very healthy diet.
I think eliminating meat
completely is a personal choice.
I don't think it's one that you normally
have to make for your health.
Albeit nutrition is an individual thing
and if your doctor recommends that
there might be a different
conversation for you.
But there's one thing that I
love about this documentary
that I want all of us
to take away from it.
We should all reduce the amount
of animal products we're eating.
We're overeating calories as is,
specifically animal product,
processed animal product.
We need to get this
garbage out of our diet.
It's one of the main reasons
obesity is overflowing
in the United States in
addition to refined carbs.
So, yes, we should lower our
reliance on animal products.
We should be eating more
fruits and vegetables.
And in fact me doing Whole 30 right now,
one of the takeaways that
I've gotten from this
is that I should be eating
more fruits and vegetables
and that I have been relying on getting
all my protein specifically
from animal sources.
So, this documentary did
bring awareness to that
and I'm really proud of it for doing so.
Just saying that we should
remove all animal products
completely as James said,
not a huge fan of that.
I don't think there's
evidence to back that up.
I think when you compare a vegan diet
to an American standard
diet, it does an amazing job
of overturning illness even.
But when you compare a
vegan diet to someone
who's otherwise healthy and omnivorous,
I've never really seen evidence to show
that vegan diet is superior.
And the interesting part about it is
most if not all major
organizations agree with that.
James made a really big deal
in the podcast saying how
Chris Kresser's views on
nutrition were not matching
scientific consensus.
Well, James's views aren't
matching scientific consensus.
I haven't seen any guidance
from the WHO or CDC
to say that we should not be eating
animal products all together.
I've seen that they recommend
that we should increase
our vegetable and fruit intake,
decrease our processed food,
refined carbs, our red
meats, our processed meats,
but to say to remove all animal products
is not scientific consensus.
I want to leave you with
some thoughts that I had
about the Joe Rogan
podcast where James Wilks
and Chris Kresser debated
about the documentary.
I know Joe Rogan framed this as a debate
where Chris debunked the documentary.
James saw that episode and
was very upset about it
and he wanted them to
sort of battle it out
or duke it out with their information.
I don't necessarily want to see a debate
from these two gentlemen.
I want to see a conversation.
A debate is contentious,
a debate is about winning.
A conversation is about
truth seeking together.
When I saw the debate
devolve into personal attacks
I felt like that was a
loss for me as a viewer.
I think that these guys are so smart.
They've done countless hours
of research between them
and they can bring a
lot to the conversation.
And I think both of these gentlemen agreed
more than they disagreed and
it didn't come off that way
by the way they were
talking with one another.
It almost seemed like they
disagreed on everything.
It's not true and I think
their only real point
of contention is should you
go 100% animal product free
or go mostly animal product free.
And I think that's such
a minute difference
that our research with the low
quality that it is right now,
I can't really tell which
one of them is right.
So, I still say to my
patients that they should
eat a predominantly plant based diet
with some animal products in there,
I put together a playlist for you
of all my nutrition videos
including going vegan
for 30 days so click here.
And if you have any residual questions,
leave them down below
in the comments section
because I want to answer them.